ces photographies ont fait le tour du
monde et les voici à gré le temps d'un
été au musée baron martin elles sont
signées yann arthus bertrand l'artiste a
photographié notre planète vue du ciel
une réalité inédite et fascinante c'est
à la fois ce plaidoyer pour sauver notre
planète et cette dénonciation de la
surexploitation humaines qui touchent
les visiteurs il ya aussi des personnes
qui se remettent en question et qui
sortent finalement un peu aussi
bouleversée de l'exposition en se
demandant parce qu'elle pourrait
entreprendre finalement pour concourir
au sauvetage en quelque sorte de notre
planète qui est le nôtre bien notre
héritage commun
hommage aussi à l'homme avec ses
portraits de vrais gens comme le dit
lui-même yann arthus bertrand le
photographe travaille pour l'histoire
avec un grand h
il le fait un peu je dirais comme un
artiste de la renaissance en nous
permettant d'entrer en contact avec ces
personnes que nous ne connaissons pas et
qui pourtant nous sont infiniment proche
la renaissance justement c'est l'âge
d'or de la ville degrés au 16e siècle
simon gotchaux dansiez et sa famille
sont les puissants de la cité leur
devise spes mais à deus dieu et mon
espérance est inscrite sur le fronton de
leur hôtel particulier
je vous ai apprécié vous êtes venus ces
appels j'arrive et là on est dans une
des plus vieilles maisons à gré bien sûr
elle date du 16e siècle est ici nous
sommes dans le domaine de la famille des
godillots une célèbre famille en franche
comté qui date du 14ème siècle et qui a
perduré jusqu'au xviie siècle
pour découvrir ce qu'il ya derrière
cette porte il suffit que les visiteurs
demandent un guide à l'office du
tourisme
et les voilà projetés dans un faible de
passer
[Musique]
voilà c'est fait
ça marche que vous
ici vous êtes devant un cylindre en
chaîne qui fait 6 mètres cinquante de
haut à l'intérieur vous avez un escalier
ici vous avez des systèmes de blocage
et d'une simple pression demain vous le
faites tourner
et vous masquez les ouvertures de deux
ore l'escalier est caché par le panneau
en bois de deux dans une surprise nous
attend et nous allons arriver dans la
chambre secrète
[Musique]
je comprends ses secrets en fait quand
ça tourne on voit par l or en fait
pourquoi il avait eu
besoin de secret si vous alors pourquoi
il a construit cette tour avec cette
cachette pour ne sais pas trop mais
comme il avait une grosse fortune
peut-être pour cacher sa fortune où se
cacher lui même en cas de problème mais
en fait ici c'est unique en europe alors
c'est unique en europe et au monde on ne
connaît pas d'autres parce qu'on a
beaucoup de touristes étrangers avec le
tourisme fluvial toute personne n'a
jamais vu cette construction c'est ça
s'appelle un escalier pivotant
les flâneurs donc à lever les yeux pour
imaginer le riche passé de gré une
fortune bâtie sur le commerce fluvial
grâce à la saône sous charles quint gré
rivalise avec dole et besançon
aujourd'hui les touristes tombe sous le
charme des bords de saône et des
vieilles pierres pour la pause ils
peuvent découvrir les spécialités de la
biscuiterie artisanale degré macarons
aux noix et où vin jaune c'est chaud
compter tous les ingrédients de ses
spécialités viennent de franche comté au
détour d'une rue du centre les visiteurs
d'un jour peuvent trouver un petit
souvenir ici les objets sont chiner ou
pas ils peuvent même repartir avec leur
caricature ça vous arrive de faire les
portraits comme ça de touristes qui
passent avec le tourisme c'est
beaucoup c'est tous les enfants
mine de rien gray est une ville au
charme discret et il ya encore bien
d'autres portes à ouvrir pour tous les
explorer